Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Mandalorian episode 6
video probably the most cameo heavy
episode so far so we'll break it down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe I'll be doing Easter Egg
videos for all the episodes because they
finally have baby Yoda merch we'll do a
giveaway for that all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet will do top 10
and Easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode the prisoner so it's mostly
meant to be a heist episode heist gone
wrong which is a trope of the heist
movie genre but it also kind of turned
into a horror movie halfway through
really reminiscent of that bad ass
ending scene from rogue one with
darth vader where everything goes red and he just ignites his a lightsaber it just
cuts through all them the mando taking
down all the other bounty hunters in the
crew but number 9 welcome back partner
in crime with a ton of cameos like I
said most cameo heavy episodes so far
the black market space station that they
arrive at at the beginning of the
episode looks just like one of the Ralph
McQuarrie concept art drawings from the
original trilogy there's an r2 unit in
the background if there's all kinds of
ships being repaired all over the place
this is just meant to give you a sense
for the scale and what they can do with
their special effects they probably
spent way more money on this episode not
only because they had way more
characters but because it was so special
effects heavy seriously you couldn't
tell the difference between this episode
and something that you would see in one
of the big Star Wars movies that is why
this series cost so much they spent
between 12 and 15 million dollars per
episode I believe the first character
that we meet is rands er mulk he just
calls him ran its guest star mark Boone
jr. from the Dark Knight trilogy a whole
bunch of stuff you probably recognize
him from somewhere he typically plays
pretty scummy characters it's implied
that he and the Mandalorian have all
this history together they used to run
jobs and they kind of imply through his
dialogue that the Mandalorian used to be
way more vicious using their jobs more
is target practice than to actually
earn money the whole reason for him
coming here is because he needs money so he had to take a job and he couldn't
take one through the guild because
they're still after his head because of
baby Yoda
he seems really old here so it's hard to
tell how long ago it was that they ran
jobs together but they imply that it was
a long time ago after the mando had put
his helmet on and when I say put the
helmet on I'm talking about adopting the
culture of the Mandalorians like they
don't take their helmets off in public
for anyone like Clancy Browns Deveraux
knee and character makes jokes about the
Mandalorians if they're the most
fearsome warriors in the galaxy that how
come they're all dead but number eight
we meet bill burrs character so most of
you probably know who bill burr is if
you're not super familiar with them his
name is Mayfield in the episode he's a
former imperial sharpshooter they make a
huge joke about the original trilogy
because the Mandalorian says that's not
saying much but then bill Burke comes
back and says I wasn't a stormtrooper
haha one of the biggest jokes about
stormtroopers from the original trilogy
is that they couldn't hit water if they
fell out of a boat he then makes a joke
about the razor crest saying that it
looks like a slot machine from Kanto
bite from the last Jedi that was the big
casino planet they went to the Deaf
Aronian is named brug obviously you
recognize him as Clancy Brown the droid
his name's zero he kind of looks like
the same type of droid his for loan from
Empire Strikes Back they were originally
protocol droids with the bug eyes he's
played by Richard I UID you probably
recognize him from the IT Crowd they
also kind of implied that he had a
relationship with the Twi'lek bounty
hunter named xi'an played by natalia
tanya from Game of Thrones in the Harry
Potter franchise her big weapon of
choices that she's really good with
throwing daggers her special daggers are
from their home planet Ryloth their
planet is noted for making really
special daggers like this they kind of
try to give each of the different bounty
hunters a special weird funny quality
like the droid keeps telling everyone
how it's smarter and better than
everyone else except for baby Yoda which
kind of makes the payoff a little bit
funnier when ninja baby Yoda totally
outsmarts the droid but number 6 we
get more of the Mandalorians earlier
more vicious history they start making
fun of the Mandalorians history
wondering how good of a fighter he
really is in the twi'lek mentions as
locke 3 that planet is a super deep cut
reference for the expanding material and
some of the video games like Star Wars
Galaxies in the Old Republic
like video game it's the home planet of
the tall's aliens these furry sentient
creatures that showed up during the
original trilogy they implied that on
one of the last jobs that he ran with
these people from the black market space
station involved him leaving them behind
or some of them behind because he says
quote unquote it was the right thing to
do most of your questions about that
though get answered by the end of the
episode bill burr makes a joke about Jar
Jar Binks when he says the Mandalorian
might be a Gungan underneath his helmet
is that why you're not taking it off
they make a big thing about him taking
it off even the Deveraux nyan later in
the episode when they're fighting tries
to forcibly take it off let's see what
you look like under that helmet they
kind of imply that she anime have seen
his face underneath the helmet because
they had a relationship with each
other but number 5 the crew meets baby
Yoda
so he gets into a fight with the
Deveraux knee and they accidentally find
out that little compartment the baby
Yoda has been hiding in this whole time
he tries to pass it off like a pet the
droid maneuvers them into the target
zone baby Yoda gets knocked around a lot
you meant to worry about him really up
until the end of the episode when it's
him versus the droid then you kind of
get a feel for what's really going on
like oh no he's totally fine he can take
care of himself but they really Led you
along with that baby Yoda plot through
the episode like the droids slowly
finding out what was going on with Creek
cargas message like oh no they're going to
try and steal him at some point but they
finally make it onto the new republic
ship and there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and cameos in this part of the
episode too so when you first see these
droids they look just like the r1
astromech droids from inside the Jawas
sandcrawler from a new hope only they've
been upgraded so they're floating around
out instead of wheeling around there are
a bunch of prisoners that they walk by I
could only spot a couple of them though
the blue alien that you see first is
actually our Din Ian that's an Easter
Egg for Jon Favreau's character from
solo a Star Wars story his character was
named Ryo Durant he was the pilot of the
ship there's a random Imperial officer
then there's a small black mouse droid
like the one from a new hope on the
Death Star
these sentry droids look kind of like
downgraded smaller versions of the older
Imperial sentry droids you kind of get a
sense for things turning in the episode
things going a little bit wrong when
bill bursts character doesn't help the
Mandalorian out it's hard to tell if
he's just impressed with the Mandalorian
like oh he doesn't need our help or if
this is him just saying oh no we're
going to double
awesome anyway so maybe he'll get killed
while he's destroying these and we won't
have to lock him up there's a really big
cameo in that New Republic guard that
they find you said it was only going to
be droids this is Matt Lanter who played
Anakin Skywalker in the Clone Wars he
did a bunch of other voices but Anakin
Skywalker was the biggest voice that he
did the uniform that he's wearing just
looks like a newer version of the rebel
fleet trooper uniforms from a new hope
at the beginning of that movie love the
way they pulled off that three-way
Mexican standoff to remember it's
supposed to be inspired by westerns and
samurai films in the three-way Mexican
standoff is a trope of western movies
most notably during the good the bad and
the ugly the homing beacon being set off
sort of gives them their ticking clock
during the episode where things really
kick into high gear in number four the
mandalorian gets thrown under the bus
when they rescue their mark the person
they're there to rescue winds up being
Quinn the very person that the
Mandalorian left behind on his big job
and as log three that they referenced
earlier in the episode turnabout is fair
play Mandalorian as he gets thrown in
the cell and they walk off Sheehan also
makes like she always wanted to destroy him later like that was always the plan that
they were supposed to get rid of him
during the job but then back on the ship
baby Yoda gets out and starts messing
with the droid so number three baby Yoda
versus the Droid so they make like this
cat-and-mouse game where the droid can't
seem to find him like he turns around
again and he's completely gone baby Yoda
using his crazy teleporting powers again
there were a lot of mr. X and because of
what we know he's already capable of we
saw him doing things in earlier episodes
like pressing buttons and using the
force they kind of made it seem like
baby Yoda was going to trick the droid into
getting into the Carbonite freezing area
and then he would just press the button
freezing him in carbonite when the droid
finds him in his compartment though they
actually make like he's going to use the
Force to deflect the blaster shot but
the Mandalorian shoots him from behind
before you can find out whether or not
he was actually going to do that but I
do think that he would have been able to
do it like he holds his hand up like
he's clearly getting ready to use the
Force when the droid raises his gun
hopefully they'll pay that off in a
later episode I feel like they're
showing us him doing these things
doesn't let you know that he's capable
of them then if everything goes the way
it should you'll see them pay that off
by seeing him actually do it by the end
of the series but then
mandalorian MacGyver's his way out of
that prison cell in number two the
Mandalorians versus all the other bounty
hunters this is the part of the episode
where things turn from being more of
like a heist genre feel to more of a
horror film all the lights go red the
Mandalorian shuts down most of the areas
on the ship trying to keep them from
taking off in the Razr crest really
likes his fight with the Deveraux nyan
you learned that he's still got some
whistling birds or maybe he just picked
up all the whistling birds all that
special best guard darts from the
stormtroopers back in episode 3 he
totally eats the Mandalorians
flamethrower there were a couple double
take twist like wait a minute what's
going to be able to take him down he tries
to get him with the door trick that he
used against the Quarren back in Episode
one that doesn't work too because he's
so strong that he just lifts the door up
but then gets him with the second blast
shield or trick from Return of the Jedi
like oh wait there's a second door to
you find out at the end of the episode
what really happened but they kind of
imply like he destroyed all those bounty
hunters at first until you find out the
twist at the end no he didn't destroy them
all he just locked them up in a Cell the
cinematography of his fight with bill
burr was probably the best but the fight
itself wasn't quite as good as the fight
with the Deveraux nyan or with a Twi'lek
but he takes them all down then takes
his mark back to the space station to
collect on the bounty the number one the
big twist ending with even more
extra-special cameos so when he takes
him back to the space station they make
like rands er mulk
in the toy like are going to destroy him
like here's your space craft go after
him gun and down but surprise he put the
tracker on him so the New Republic fleet
will arrive and take care of them for
the Mandalorian in the three pilots are
Dave Filoni himself
Rick family WA and Deborah chow all
directors of the episode although Dave
floating himself is one of the
co-creators and one of the executive
producers this is also a bit of a meta
Easter Egg for Star Wars a new hope
because when they did the Death Star
trench run with all the rebel pilots at
the end of episode 4 most of the actual
pilots were just people from the crew or
producers George Lucas just needed a
bunch of warm bodies so instead of
picking traditional actors he just
picked people from the crew but they
actually gave them names so Dave
felonious name is trapper wolf which I
believe is a reference to trapper one of
the clone troopers that served with mace
windu during the Clone Wars series in
the wolf part of his name is just a
reference to the loft wolf from the
our Wars rebels series did really strong
connections to the force and just like
the been do they were neither good nor
bad the loft wolves were just as really
big canonical thing as part of that
series
Rick famuyiwa directed this episode
himself he also directed one of the
earlier episodes
his name was jib Dodger and then Deborah
Chows name was sash Kenner she directed episode three still probably the best
episode of the series so far she's also
directing episode 7 I believe there's no
big post-credit scene or anything like
that but baby Yoda joins him in the
cockpit and he jokes to him I told you
this would be a bad idea as they slammed
two credits if he spotted any other big
Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
big reminder this is a big week for Star
Wars so episode 7 the next episode will
be on Wednesday December 18th instead of next Fridays we get it a couple days
early that's because Star Wars Episode
nine drops next Friday they didn't want
to have a big scheduling conflict but
episode eight will be the next Friday
though so it'll go back to the regular
schedule for the finale just in case I
do get to see Star Wars Episode 9
early next week I will post a
non-spoilery review when they let us but
all my regular review and Easter Egg
videos full breakdowns will post next
weekend after everyone has a chance to
see the movie also try to do another
Mandalorian bonus video this weekend but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
congratulations Mike Mele you're the
giveaway winner from my last big man to
lorraine video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here from my Mandalorian Episode 5
video and all the other
episode videos and click here for my new
baby Yoda video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!